battle for 2020 officially kicks off
with the Iowa caucuses just a few hours
from now the Hawkeye State could prove
to be a pivotal moment and the
Democratic race the party's
establishment is bracing for a Bernie
Sanders surge while sleepy Joe Biden's
allies are preparing for the worst
here's the top candidates making their
final pitches I feel good
there's a lot of energy out there
there's a lot of enthusiasm been a lot
of counties and all over the country all
over the state and it feels good
commit today to caucus for me agree to
do phone calls knock on doors while
Democrats battle it out in Iowa
President Trump continues to steal the
spotlight and there's growing concern
among the party that 2020 candidates
don't stand a chance against Trump
especially when facing attacks like
these but I'm watching and you know I
have a little nicknames for all of them
but but you just I'm sure that nicknames
but they're accurate they'll start with
Joe Biden
I just think of Sleepy Eye I just watch
him he's sleepy sleepy Joe hunter hunter
Biden where's dr. Bernie Sanders
well I think he's a communist you
mentioned now Elizabeth Warren she's not
true to it I call a fairytale because
everything's a fairy tale all right
Juan Williams so you're in Iowa now what
have you heard what are you seeing out
there where do you see the energy
leading to if you can give us a sense of
that well the polls and a lot of people
are just saying they assume that Bernie
Sanders comes out on top here Jesse but
it's by three to five points at best and
so you're going to still see Joe Biden
right there and then behind that you get
Pete Budaj coming in maybe a little
farther down and the questions of the
night have to do with Amy Klobuchar the
senator from neighboring Minnesota how
will she do and there's a lot of
pessimism and I was surprised to hear
this about Elizabeth Warren Elizabeth
Warren from Massachusetts but as you
know she
while had really surged and now it looks
like this is Bernie Sanders surge at
just the right moment and it could be
crushing for Elizabeth Warren yeah I
mean she had the medicare-for-all
problem Dana she was kind of out of
commission
in the in Washington DC for the last two
weeks and then she played the victim
card against Bernie and and she's
looking like she's tailing off a little
bit do you agree with whan that it's
kind of a two-person race now in Iowa
between Biden and Bernie not I don't
think I'm quite there yet but I think
anybody including all of us here who
think that we know what's gonna happen
tonight we don't the rules changed since
the last time around in 2016 there's a
new threshold you have to hit at 15%
then it goes to a second ballot in
alignment and it's a little bit
confusing I think that the end result
tonight could be fairly muddled or you
could see Bernie Sanders do really quite
well I think that mayor Pete or may even
Andrew yang could do well here they have
a lot of enthusiasm from young people
don't forget Amy Klobuchar who really
campaigned really hard in the rural
areas she could possibly do well but I
think for Liz Warren if if she doesn't
do well here and Bernie Sanders does and
he goes to New Hampshire the King again
I think it would be really interesting
to see what she decides to do does she
continue or does she just get behind him
yeah I mean if I were running against
Bernie Sanders I'd say you're you've
already admitted that you're gonna raise
taxes Kati
on the middle class I don't know why
they're not doing that can I play a
sound bite of hold on your favorite
people Chris Matthews on MSNBC this is
his interpretation of the field one of
my thoughts I'm not happy I'm not happy
with this field I think they got to find
a candidate for president
they could be Trump and you don't think
anybody in this time looking I'm still
looking still looking what's the problem
obvious problems they're all problems
Bernie Sanders is not going to
presidented States Wow
you know I was thinking today about all
of the people who haven't made it to the
Iowa caucuses if beta was supposed to be
like the next who totally what had this
big moment and was on the front of
Vanity Fair and then fizzled out Kamala
Harris she kept saying I'm gonna move to
Iowa that didn't happen so it's really
hard to gauge what's going on in the
ground pulling his notoriously difficult
in Iowa but Bernie Sanders has been here
before and he doesn't want to lose again
so he's been able to learn from maybe
some of the mistakes or things that they
didn't do last time and really get out
there and knock on doors and I think it
lives with Warren as to Dana's point the
point if he does she doesn't do well
which I don't think she will double in
New Hampshire or Iowa she'll probably
drop out and for Joe Biden look they've
been saying forever that it doesn't
matter if he wins Iowa it doesn't matter
if you win this New Hampshire they're
banking on South Carolina to get him
through that's an interesting strategy
and their excuses for losing if that
happens tonight will be interesting to
pay attention to if they change their
strategy big fun yeah and setting
expectations pretty low all right Greg
yes I know you're gonna be watching the
caucuses tonight like a hawk
like a hawk excited well first of all
you're welcome America this is the day
after the Super Bowl
when 60% of the five are hungover unlike
the 18 million people who decided not to
show up for work we are here because we
love you even though I'm holding onto
this table praying that I make it
through without vomiting on Jetsons nice
suit all right here's the interesting
thing about this thing that what Chris
Wallace is talking about a lot of
interesting people are not running
they're not participating so this crew
seems very weak in bland it reminds me
of when you when you were a kid and your
parents bought that variety set
breakfast cereals love them those were
great for vacation but by that by the
end of the first week all that was left
was Special K and bran flakes always
special okay right weird box and and
everything from frosted flakes to Appl
Jacks they were gone willed the problem
with this field it's all bran flakes and
Special K especially mayor Pete here's
another now mayor Pete is great when
he's around others because it seems
interesting he's like a great secondary
character in a TV show but when they
decide to spin him off he's a flop so
you remembered how much you loved Joey
on friends he was great but you didn't
watch Joey did you let Joey die on the
vine because it was like it wasn't the
same with
Rachel or Ross and the thing is without
other people to compare him to it's not
going to happen as for Bernie we've been
talking about Bernie for a long time and
I call this the pendulum the populist
Inferno that took over 2016 is now
swinging back to the left all these
things are cyclical right so we add them
we had the populist inferno that brought
in Trump the populist inferno same
mentality could bring Bernie into the
White House so when I hear the sentiment
bug by Chris Matthews that'll never
happen
all right hey I said that about Trump
mm-hmm I was wrong you know you're gonna
listen to what never mind you're very
you're very good on the day after the
Super Bowl you know why because I'm
crying inside Jesse okay I'm glad I'm
sorry I only disagree with you on one
thing though I would say the never
Bernie movement is good is 10 times
stronger than the never Trump movement
and and I and you can see that never
Bernie movement already pulling out all
the stops with you know reinvigorating
the power the super-delegates letting
the rules change so Bloomberg kidding
Hillary coming out of nowhere to drop
bombs on Bernie I just I just think
Bernie as a lot coming if he wins Iowa
New Hampshire I don't know if I I don't
know if you can hear me Jesse but I
think I absolutely I think that that's
very true because it's it's not just
about a difference in style right or
indifference of like rhetoric or
demeanor or civility it is a complete
departure from a lot of things that we
hold dear in America and I think that
from the policy standpoint the
enthusiasm for a Bernie candidacy he'll
have his people in the office like 40%
but I don't think the rest of the
Democratic Party will enthusiastically
get behind him in 2016 the Republican
establishment was so anti Trump and
didn't think Trump right could beat the
Democrat that was a lot more about style
than it was about policy what the
president Trump was when as a candidate
wasn't talking about the things like a
wholesale departure that's the American
Way of life right and I still think
Bernie has only 20 percent of the
Democratic field I don't think he's a
majority
type of candy but you